critical race theory who knew that
that was the threat to our republic um
we did
because you were the one who started
promoting it in order for those
hierarchies to be torn down
your fundamental rights must be abridged
as i've been talking about here what you
can see is a
sort of woke coalition that is
mobilizing against symbols of unity
that's the reason why we're even having
a discussion about why we should put up
lgbt flags
at defense department bases it's it's a
wild idea
from the very beginning it's also the
reason why for example the democratic
party has decided that they are no
longer going to call mothers mothers
i used to every joke that i used to tell
is now a reality so i
you for years i was telling the joke
because this is what democrats
apparently think about the nature of sex
and gender
that every mother's day is actually
primary legal guardian of unspecified
gender day and every father's day
is secondary legal guardian of
unspecified gender day well now
it's not even a joke anymore this is
stuff they are literally writing into
legislation
according to the washington free beacon
president joe biden embraced the woke
terminology favor by radical left-wing
activists in his 2022 budget proposal it
refers to mothers as birthing people
birthing people yes we used to call
those women birthing people
now men can also have babies which of
course is a lie and
a one of these stupider ideas ever
posited
by anybody who has even a half
functional prefrontal cortex
birthing people birthing people like
really
impenis to people for me like what what
is this nonsense
the text of biden's record-breaking six
trillion dollar budget unveiled last
month
includes a section highlighting more
than 200 million dollars in health care
spending aimed
at reducing the quote high rate of
maternal mortality
and race-based disparities in outcomes
among birthing people so first of all
even this is gendered language why
maternal mortality why not just
mortality
maternal mortality that i mean maternal
means motherly so i
mean they got to get rid of that but
again the whole goal here is to tear
down definitions and true courage
is tearing down those definitions and
tearing down your rights in the process
because this is broader than merely
tearing away definitions or redefining
things
it is the militarization of this
approach
it's not enough to redefine things it's
not enough to tear down the hierarchies
in order for those hierarchies to be
torn down your fundamental rights must
be abridged
your rights of freedom of speech must be
abridged your right to freedom of
religion
must be a bridge for the last again the
true courage today
is in identifying how you want
internally and forcing the rest of
society
to shift its entire perspective on life
in order to account for your perspective
the rest of society has to adjust and
what that means is that their rights
must be abridged this is this is the
reason why
there's a case that's going to the
supreme court right now about whether
catholic charities ought to be able to
engage in foster decisions whether they
ought to be able to have foster homes
and whether they also have foster
agencies and the case being made is that
because catholics
actually believe in one man one woman as
the standard for marriage
and believe that man woman child is the
model
for a traditional and healthy family
that they have to be discriminated
against because if they were allowed to
actually go
forward with their foster agencies what
they would be doing is acting in
discriminatory fashion
and reins reinstituting the hierarchy
that the truly brave courageous people
are fighting to tear down freedom of
religion has to be abridged
the the basic notion of children having
a mother and a father has to be abridged
in deference to a redefinition and every
time you fight the patriarchy by
identifying
in a way that runs contrary to biology
this means that you are a brave person
braver
even than the people who stormed the
beaches of normandy who of course were
fighting on behalf of a bad cause i mean
they were fighting
truly on behalf of a reinstitution of
hierarchies just
slightly better hierarchies than the
hierarchies that were being pushed by
america's fascist enemies at the time
and you're seeing america's quote
unquote liberal institutions fall to
exactly this they have joined the woke
coalition which again
is oriented toward the destruction of
all systems of power
despite the fact that the american
systems of power which have been
gradually broadened to include more
people over time
in great and good ways despite the fact
that those systems have provided
more health more prosperity more freedom
than any systems in the history of man
by a long shot by the way those systems
have to be torn down and the aclu is now
on the side of the tearing down so the
american civil liberties union you may
notice the words civil liberties in the
middle of their title
the american civil liberties union has
now decided that civil liberties are of
no consequence whatsoever michael powell
has a piece in the new york times titled
once a bastion of free speech
the aclu faces an identity crisis it was
supposed to be the celebration of a
grand career
as the american civil liberties union
presented a prestigious award to the
long-time lawyer david goldberger
he had argued one of its most famous
cases defending the free speech rights
of nazis in the 1970s to march in skokie
illinois
home to many holocaust survivors mr
goldberger now 79 adored the aclu but at
his celebratory luncheon in 2017
he listened one speaker after another
and felt a growing unease
a law professor argued that the free
speech rights of the far right were not
worthy of defense by the aclu
and that black people experienced
defensive speech far more viscerally
than white allies
in the hallway outside an aclu official
argued it was perfectly legitimate for
his lawyers to decline
to defend hate speech mr goldberger a
jew who defended the free speech of
those whose views he found repugnant
felt felt profoundly discouraged i got
the sense it was more important for aclu
staff to identify with clients and
progressive causes than to stand on
principle
he said in a recent interview liberals
are leaving the first amendment behind
now here's the thing they are standing
on principle their principles are just
not your principles their principles are
not even tolerant of your principles
their principles are about tearing down
the systems they have to have
the aclu stripe and that bizarre flag
that we saw earlier in which everybody
has their stripe so as to create a
coalition
against the presumed systems of power
according to the new york times the aclu
america's high temple of free speech and
civil liberties has emerged as a
muscular and richly funded progressive
powerhouse in recent years
taking on the trump administration in
more than 400 lawsuits
but the organization finds itself riven
with internal tensions over whether
it has stepped away from founding
principle unwavering devotion to the
first amendment
its national and state and state staff
members debate often hotly whether
defense of speech conflicts with
advocacy for a growing number of
progressive causes
including voting rights reparations
transgender rights and defunding the
police
so for example the new york times points
out that
chase strangio the lawyer for the for
the
transgender wing of the aclu
openly push for censorship of a book by
abigail schreier now the new york times
is so unbelievably gutless that they
wouldn't even mention abigail schreier's
book here
i kid you not like they literally will
not mention abigail schreier's book
anywhere in the article
because they too are cowards when it
comes to defense of free speech
the new york times but it is truly
incredible how the
the aclu is an excellent bellwether for
the movement of the left
which at least used to agree on certain
basic principles but no longer
now the basic principle is tear down the
system and if you're
and you have to be complicit in this it
is required that you be complicit in
this
you have to shout your true bravery is
again
in supposedly risking but mostly on
behalf of a higher goal and the higher
goal is tearing down so you have
a letter a letter from the editor of the
of the national geographic
talking about the so-called race card
project again this is national
geographic a magazine dedicated to human
diversity
and differences in thought and and all
sorts and nature
it's it's literally called national
geographic
right and national geographic instead
issues a letter from the editor
about the history of race in america in
which she asks
everybody to literally carry around a
race card i'm not kidding you
quote more than a decade ago writer
michelle morris began the race card
project
in which she asked people to think about
the word race and boil their thoughts
down to six words she expected few would
respond
she was wrong so far more than 500 000
people have written six word micro
essays about race
hailing from every state in about 100
countries and territories
michelle recently has brought the race
card project to the national geographic
society as a storytelling fellow
we'll support norris in using a wealth
of tools audio video animation
cartography photography our technology
to bring the project's archived stories
to life these aren't just binary
conversations about black and white
people this quilt as she describes it
pulls at all manners of cultural threads
from latinos and indigenous people to
asians and iranians
so what's my race card right susan
goldberg the editor in chief of national
geographic
this is a hard exercise but reflecting
on the difficult past year on our fraud
politics and so many frank conversations
i've had with friends and colleagues for
now
i'll leave it at this white privileged
with much to learn
okay now some of us would call this
cowardice someone should say that you
are attempting to avoid the cancellation
of the woke mob because after all
it sounds from your name as though
you're a jewish woman who is editing a
major magazine and anytime you want you
could theoretically give up that slot to
a person of color if you are so
dedicated to the proposition
that systems of power in the united
states are biased toward white people
and jews
but you're not going to do that so
instead you're going to virtue signal
but according to the left this is
internet she's expressing her authentic
fears or authentic ones and that
authenticity is directed at tearing down
the system
this is the new form of courage and this
form of courage is going to be taught in
america's public schools this is what
critical race theory effectively is
it's teaching you that true bravery lies
in taking on this this is the
anti-racism
of ibrahim x candy it is the critical
race theory of derek bell
that true bravery lies in speaking truth
to power
and speaking truth to power means
tearing down all the systems and this
sort of new redefinition of courage this
sort of new redefinition
of national mission is being promoted by
none other than barack obama one of the
most divisive political figures of my
lifetime i think maybe the most
divisive political figure of my lifetime
and yes i'm including president trump in
there
because president trump followed obama
and there was a reason for that barack
obama
deliberately decided he could have been
a unifying president in 2008 he came
along and said
no red sleets no blue states no black
americans no white americans just just
americans
and then he immediately proceeded to
polarize americans along racial lines
along gender lines along lines of sexual
orientation and he proceeded to try to
cobble together a coalition to take down
the systems of power and enshrine
himself in power at the exact same time
and now of course
what is he pushing forward he's pushing
for a critical race theory which is not
a shock considering
that he was a proponent of critical race
theory back in the 1980s he was
literally
hugging derek bell right one of the
founders and promoters of critical race
theory in the 1980s when derek bell was
denied tenure at harvard law school so
here's barack obama
complaining that republicans have
noticed what he is doing
you would think with all the public
policy debates that are taking place
right now
that you know the republican party would
uh be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most important
issue to them apparently right now is
critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
um we did because you were the one who
started promoting it
mr president you were the one who
decided that it was very important to
polarize americans along racial lines
and suggest that all the systems of
power of america
were significantly infused and indeed
irredeemably infused with white
supremacy
right and again the goal here for the
left is continue to form that coalition
it's all about the coalition which is of
course why barack obama is blaming a
rise of anti-semitism
on not his own party not his own actions
by the way in supporting the iranian
regime or supporting
the palestinian regime no instead barack
obama
is blaming donald trump and republicans
despite the fact that the radical uptick
in anti-semitism we have seen over the
past couple of years
is deeply tied into the to the left-wing
ideologies
that are associated with black lives
matter that are associated with the
pro-palestinian cause
that are associated with with his own
sort of conspiratorial viewpoint
on hierarchies of power in the united
states i've noticed that barack obama
isn't spending any time condemning for
example ilhan omar
who's out there comparing israel to
hamas he's only com he's only condemning
trump suggesting that trump is
responsible for anti-semitism
again this is courage according to the
left because courage is dependent on the
final goal in the aristotelian
notion this is why barack obama's yeah
why are you paying why are you paying
attention to critical race theory
why do you care for indoctrinating your
kids and the idea that true bravery lies
in authentically identifying as less if
they're a member of a particular race
also i'm going to stand up for the most
radical members of my coalition
okay now what this is going to lead to
of course
is eventually a breakdown in the
coalition we're in a battle for the
culture and for our values
like and subscribe to help keep our
videos on the front line of the fight
and top of your feed